eins steht fest meine damen und herren
corona verstärkt weltweit autoritäre
tendenzen und ist in vielen ländern eine
echte bedrohung für die pressefreiheit
geht mit china los das ja schon vor der
seuche nicht gerade musterdemokratie war
jetzt gehen die chinesen wirklich sehr
weit um ihre version der pandemie
geschichte zu verbreiten
da werden ganz spezielle
sprachregelungen regelrecht befohlen
laut bundesregierung haben chinesische
diplomaten versucht deutsche beamte zu
beeinflussen sie sollten sich positiv
über das chinesische corona management
äußern
die bundesregierung betonte den
aufforderungen nicht nachgekommen zu
sein
gut dass er mutig das aber mutig peking
macht eine ansage und wir kommen dem
einfachen nicht nach sicher man hätte
als kroko auch mal laut und böse
protestieren können gegen diese
unverschämtheit aber nicht nachkommen
ist ja auch irgendwie widerstand die
australier haben gerade eine unabhängige
untersuchung zur entstehung des corona
virus gefordert und prompt droht china
mit einem boykott australischer waren ja
brück hat ich sage ihnen jeder kriegt
ärger der an deren krone weit auch nur
leise zweifel anmeldet natürlich machen
die chinesen auch vieles richtig
zum beispiel die idee mit den
abstandshalter mützen in chinesischen
grundschule die ist gar nicht schlecht
praktisch und süß zu beginn der solche
haben chinesische behörden eindeutig
versucht das ganze coroner thema erstmal
zu vertuschen ist und auch wenn das
regime seit januar mit effektiven
maßnahmen erfolgreich gegen krone kämpft
kritik war und bleibt bei denen
unerwünscht um es mal vorsichtig
auszudrücken
sie ist anwalt und kam am 24 januar nach
doha nun über die lage dort als
bürgerreporter in den sozialen medien zu
berichten
er prangerte an dass es nicht genug
schutzkleidung und masken und es gab
auch von ihm fehlt seit wochen jede spur
hunderte bürgerreporter blogger kritiker
sind
irgendwie weg zusammen mit russland
liefert vor allem peking weltweit
desinformation und fake news zu coroner
gleichzeitig verbreiten sie mit
nachdruck ihre narrativ china hat von
anfang an alles richtig gemacht und der
schwache westen sollte sich gefälligst
mal bedanken den den staatsmedien lassen
sich chinas kommunisten und ihre armee
schon ausgiebig als bezwinger der solche
feiern bewundert und geliebt nicht nur
von den massen daheim muss ich
eigentlich mitklatschen
ich mach das mal lieber ja und ganz
nebenbei treiben die chinesen noch einen
keil in die eu erfolgreich allerdings
mit deutscher hilfe
während wir in den ersten tagen der
krise erst mal aufgehört haben
schutzkleidung zu exportieren hat china
in italien medienwirksam geholfen
heute sagen 45 prozent der italiener
deutschland ist unser feind nummer eins
52 prozent halten china für italiens
besten freund haben wir selber verbockt
und in sachen eigen pr macht den
chinesen eh keiner was vor
die rede
dem dbb
happy end schon zwei tage später konnte
dieses baby zu seiner ersten frühschicht
in die handy fabrik meine damen und
herren ja wahrscheinlich nur eine frage
der zeit bis sich pekings
propagandaabteilung direkt an
deutschland wendet deutschland wenn ihr
unsere lieblings kolonie bleiben wollt
ist das hier die einzige wahrheit über
corona gezüchtet wurde das virus
natürlich in den usa diesen schuld ganz
alleine
aber dann hat chinas herrscher der
größte und potenteste präsident des
universums die solche für immer besiegt
geiler typ und wenn ihr kartoffel
fresser noch mal was anderes sagt nehmen
wir euch alles weg was sie in china
hergestellt wird
smartphones tablets der fernseher und
ratet mal wo eure scheiße kuckucksuhr
gebaut wird genau alle spielkonsolen das
heißt eure dicken kinder können wieder
mit der holzeisenbahn spielen kapiert
und denkt dran wir haben euch im auge
botschaft angekommen steht so im
medizinlexikon dem krempel corona
nebenwirkung nachlassende pressefreiheit
leider laut reporter ohne grenzen
passiert das gerade im iran in honduras
ägypten venezuela und auf den
philippinen wurde ihre präsident du
tertre 120000 menschen wegen verletzung
der lockdown regeln ins gefängnis
gesperrt hat so und jetzt kommt der
hammer freunde ausgerechnet der sultan
ausgerechnet recep tayyip erdogan der
boss vom bosporus verkündet derweil eine
amnestie für gefangene für welche diebe
räuber oder gewalttäter landesweit
kommen 90.000 insassen vorzeitig frei
darunter auch ein berüchtigter mafiaboss
von dem gesetz ist jedoch eine gruppe
gänzlich ausgeschlossen
politische gefangene die journalistin
ist mafia boss und türkischer
staatspräsident nicht ohnehin irgendwie
das gleiche übrigens der chef der
türkischen religionsbehörde sagt
homosexualität sei mitschuld am ausbruch
von corona meine theorie ist ja das
virus ist von einer ziege auf den
menschen übergesprungen aber ich bin ja
auch nur laie und wenn sie jetzt glauben
dass wir hier in der demokratischen eu
vor unterdrückung der pressefreiheit
sicher sind pustekuchen poster wegen
ungarn jetzt drohen journalisten bis zu
fünf jahren haft wenn sie meldungen
verbreiten die die regierung als fake
news klassifiziert damit hat orban de
facto einen sanktionsmittel gegen
kritische berichte man darf bestimmen
was fake news sind da kannst du auch hdi
110 zum frauenbeauftragten machen der
gulasch motoren hier kann jetzt über
jahre per dekret regieren
und was macht unsere eu die ist
menschlich enttäuscht sämtliche eu
gelder an ungarn fließen fröhlich weiter
und man hat orban immer noch nicht final
aus der konservativen parteienfamilie
evp er rausgeschmissen
dabei hat es doch dieser fidele renten
aus luxemburg schon vor jahren
vorgemacht
warum hat eigentlich richtig zu bauen
ihre kommission wollen derweil die lage
in ungarn sehr intensiv beobachten zitat
ende
da weint sich der orban bestimmt jeder
nach vor angst in den schlaf übrigens
auch in deutschland befürchten menschen
corona bedingt diktatorische tendenzen
sebastian pufpaff zum beispiel erhält
jetzt jeden abend mahnwache vor dem
kanzleramt in berlin um gegen was genau
zu demonstrieren ja aufwachen welche man
glaubens hier die grundrechte und allen
ist das egal
seit dienstag können wir unser
grundgesetz im prinzip wegschmeißen ja
oberflächlich ist das hier vielleicht
noch so eine art demokratie aber drunter
längst ddr 2.0 mit einem hauch nordkorea
bitte was ist denn dienstag passiert was
ist passiert was ist passiert das ist
passiert holz die neue
straßenverkehrsordnung soll vor allem
radfahrer stärken
die dürfen ab heute auch nebeneinander
fahren autofahrer die harte oder gehwege
blockieren müssen mit 100 euro bußgeld
rechnen
herzlich willkommen im grünen fahrrad
faschismus volks fahrräder volks
fahrräder
ich packe jetzt so lange mit meinem
porsche direkt vom merkels plattenbau
wie sie den gesamten quatsch wieder
zurücknimmt die bußgelder haben sich im
schnitt verdoppelt dafür sind die
menschen 980 nicht auf die straße
gegangen
das sind jetzt mit corona zu tun wir
haben augen sehe warum das merke regime
genau jetzt mit so einem totalitären
bußgeldkatalog um die ecke kommt damit
keiner mitkriegt vor lauter corona ab
sofort 5 50 euro fürs parken in adobe
das trägt doch eindeutig die handschrift
von diesem professor drosten was die 21
km h zu schnell in der stadt sagt 80
euro im monat in langen weg wir müssen
so aufpassen welche heute darf und nicht
mehr mit 70 durch die spielstraße
müllern morgen stimmt die pressefreiheit
und später fragt mich mein enkel hopper
und wo warst du als die raser abgeholt
wurden warum hast du es nicht verhindert
warum warum hier geht jetzt aber einiges
durcheinander würde die schweine zwingt
mich ein meter fünfzig jahren
frenz fahrradfahren zu halten sind die
ehre ich sehe sie normalerweise so nah
an dem vorbei dass ich sehe die ihre
nasenhaare vor angst zitternd nur dann
kapieren die nämlich dass sie auf der
straße nichts verloren haben wir müssen
uns jetzt wären sonst sind solche sehen
hier bald alltag mit 66 grad gemessen
wurden
und da geht zwar eine toleranz von 3 km
h schneller bei ihm ist pizza drin man
pizzaboten das rückgrat unserer
gesellschaft werden von uniformierten
wegelagerern terrorisiert und meine
quattro stagioni hilft nur noch lauwarm
und durch gefettet aus dem karton danke
merkel
also herr prof in vielen nachbarländern
zahlt man nach wie vor deutlich mehr
da fehlt jetzt jede innere logik
beispiel in der rettungsgasse gibt's
nicht am stau vorbei fahren gibt zwei
punkte warum wenn da gar kein
rettungswagen fährt dann ist er doch
platz war einfach mal mit denken bevor
man sich so ein scheiß ausdenkt die
soziale jetzt 55 euro fürs parken auf
einem autoparkplatz e-autos sind
überhaupt keine autos sind da sind
behinderten rollstühle mit dach wieso
kriegen den parkplatz begerow das sind
alles sicherlich berechtigten fragen und
sagen sie mal man lässt sie da jetzt
jeden abend vor dem kanzleramt
nein quatsch ich stehe wie in der
feuerwehr einfahrt
ich frage ganz regulär auf dem radweg
auch wenn er jetzt eine schramme in der
karre ist super snake ich verklagt wie
grün blau verdammt tag man kann noch
nicht mal in ruhe demonstrieren welche
volksverräter volkswagen bastian pusch
sebastian pufpaff so das war fast von
uns fast denn nach so viel eher
traurigen kram wollten wir heute mal
unbedingt mit einer positiven note enden
friedemann weise fordert endlich gute
nachrichten dann kommt das literarische
quartett und wir sehen uns nächste woche
wieder bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]
nur kurz zum leben sonst bleibe ich zu
hause ich heute abstand ich spende
und trotzdem kommen
[Musik]
als jetzt so schlimm
echte schreiben
[Musik]
silber
achtung achtung das ist ein ultimatum
wenn ich bis morgen 8 uhr
dann sich gezwungen der selbst einst zu
machen ja ja
[Musik]
hey
also das krankenhauspersonal
[Musik]
ihr seid noch mal ran
in den vier jahren
dazu
ohne miete zu zahlen und kriege sind
verboten
griechischen insel
können wieder
die genutzt der flüchtlinge sind nach
hause oder bei uns
in der pflege
[Musik]
den stoff zu finden wird
für dich ein impfstoff gegen alle iphone
apps gefunden
eine spritze für alle die porto
so ein komisches möglichkeit gefühl war
sich manchmal morgens alles wird schön
frostig
gegen viele kinder
wenn sie nicht gestorben sind
dann rechnen sie noch immer das wird
schön
[Musik]
da
trotzdem so
heute war dass man viel mehr schwarz so
einfach
und kurz vor schluss
einfach so was ich wirklich nicht auf
fußball theorie
[Musik]
alter der club hatte er wieder alles
wahnsinn inhaltlich stark satire comedy
grotte
ich habe es noch drauf also ich würde
den kanal direkt abonnieren und auf
gefällt mir drücken wenn ich das nicht
schon getan hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]